يوتيوب: لا، ولكن هل يمكننا التحدث عن
العقيدة الفلسطينية بسرعة حقيقية لأنها
لا تشبه أي شيء رأيته من قبل، فهم
لا يريدون أن يعرف الناس أن
الصهاينة يدفعون لأصحاب النفوذ
لدعم إسرائيل، كانت هذه رسالة بريد إلكتروني
تلقيتها تعرض عليّ مبلغ
5000 دولار،
لذا طردت جلوبال نيوز  لتحدثي
عن فلسطين على حساباتي على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
كوني الصحفي الفلسطيني الوحيد
في غرفة الأخبار، اعتقدت أن
صوتي سيكون الأكثر أهمية بالنسبة لهم
خلال هذه
الأوقات [تصفيق] [
موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
حسنًا، من أجل الإجابة على هذا السؤال
بشكل صحيح  لنرجع بضع خطوات إلى الوراء أم
لنتفق جميعا على أن إسرائيل
تمتلك حاليا أه القدرات العسكرية
لمحو غزة من الكوكب وقتل
2.1 مليون فلسطيني، فإذا أه
كانت غزة مزعجة لإسرائيل إلى هذا الحد أه طوال
تلك السنوات
يأتي السؤال لماذا لم يفعلوا ذلك
بالفعل، فهي بالتأكيد ليست
أخلاقهم أه وليس حقيقة أه
سوف يتلقون رد فعل عنيف أه
من المجتمع الدولي
بفعلهم ذلك أه لذلك من المهم أه
فهم أن التغطية الإعلامية  يلعب
دورا كبيرا إلى حد ما في ما
يمكن أن تقوم به إسرائيل أه أه لذا من
المهم أن تكون هناك رسالة موحدة أه
أه للعالم في هذا الشأن
ما قمت به شخصيا في
أوقات هذه الحرب أم أنا'  لقد أنشأنا
مجموعة مع أصدقاء آخرين لديهم
أه متابعة كبيرة على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وتأثير هائل وتتكون تلك المجموعة
من أكثر من 250 أه شخص لهم
حضور كبير على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي من جميع أنحاء
الدول العربية وهدفنا هو
إيصال رسالة موحدة
كفلسطينيين  أو كداعمين للقضية
الفلسطينية أمام بقية دول
العالم أه لنوضح ذلك أكثر أم
من خلال حملاتنا ومن خلال
عكس الصورة الصحيحة للعالم
يمكننا التأثير على اقتصاد
إسرائيل أه من خلال فضح
عملتهم أه من خلال أم منع
المستثمرين  من الاستثمار في إسرائيل
عن طريق أيضا أه خفض
أسعار السياحة أه لذلك هذا ليس فقط مسألة
ما يحدث على الأرض
يمكننا جميعا أن نلعب جزءا من هذه الحرب يمكننا جميعا
دعم قوى المقاومة وهم
بحاجة إلينا يحتاجون إلينا الآن أكثر  من أي
وقت آخر